good morning John
so there have been a bunch of times over
the last
few weeks when this has become more and
more real uh this is the big one though
so I uh notice that my lymph nodes were
big I talked to my doctor she says
probably nothing will send you in for an
ultrasound got an ultrasound the tech
and the ultrasound room was like I'm
gonna go get a doctor
that's not what you want to have happen
she was great at the tech and so was the
doctor and they're like this looks like
it could be suspicious uh for lymphoma
and we'll get you in for a biopsy and
then I took the order for the surgery
like the paperwork down to the surgery
office and I like gave it to the woman
in the window and she's like who hand
delivery and I was like well yeah the
surgery is tomorrow and she's like oh
procrastinator and I was like well no
just got scheduled just now and shoot
and then like like her eyes change it's
like when you're in the American Health
Care System uh you don't expect things
to move quick like that's not what it
that's not what it does that's not what
it looks like and then when it starts to
get a little bit efficient uh it's
actually quite disconcerting I've seen
that so many times and it doesn't look
like that what's happening right now
it's like seeing a horse that has hands
it's just not that's very upsetting like
it's good I'm glad everybody's taking
things seriously right now but holy so
her eyes change and it's like seeing a
flight attendant on a plane that's in
the air running down the aisle like that
can't be good I just either somebody or
everybody's having a very bad day
because I don't know all the noises a
plane makes and I don't know all the
ways that the Health Care system works
but you do and you look like something
is weird I already knew it was weird
though everybody has been great and very
supportive but biopsy
uh good news bad news uh one it's cancer
it's called lymphoma it's a cancer of
the lymphatic system
um and the good news is something called
Hodgkin's lymphoma it's the most
treatable like one of the most treatable
cancers
um it responds very well to treatment
the goal was cure the procedure to get
there is fairly well known if unpleasant
I have a friend amazingly enough who has
been through a diagnosis and treatment
and remission and is 10 years post with
Hodgkin's lymphoma it's been really nice
to have that in my back pocket for
texting and being like is this normal
and am I panicking and
um please tell me I'm gonna be okay but
the treatment is a fairly well
established like system of
chemotherapies which I'm going to start
very soon
um not looking really forward to it but
I'm looking forward to starting on the
path yeah prognosis is very good for
people with Hodgkin's lymphoma it seems
likely that we caught mine early really
I'm still waiting on a scan to sort of
confirm that but even when it's not
super early even when it's in multiple
parts of the body Hodgkin's is super
treatable like solid Mass tumors like
lung cancer prostate cancer
um to figure out how to live somewhere
else in the body is like a really big
leap for them it means that they've
changed and they've evolved and they've
got like a bunch of new strategies for
survival which is why metastasis and
solid cancers is a really big deal this
is a blood cancer so it's a cancer of
the immune cells the lymphocytes and so
they are already all over the body other
parts of the body are like hey yo that
you're you're fine here whereas like
prostate cells in the lungs would
normally get attacked and so prostate
cancer cells in the lungs means that
they've developed a whole set of new
strategies lymphoma cells don't have to
do that so it doesn't mean something
super bad if lymphoma has spread
um it's worse for clarity but it's not
the same giant gap between like stage
one and stage four with lymphoma as it
is with solid Mass tumors anyway I have
a bunch of risk factors for lymphoma
including medications I've taken
including the fact that I have an
autoimmune disease include in fact that
I had Mono when I was a kid all these
are are risk factors
um so it was something that I was
looking out for and have been aware of
I'm glad everybody took it seriously and
we got a diagnosis pretty quick I said
this to you already John I said um
you know this is the best time so far in
human history to get lymphoma which is a
very Hank Green thought and then you
would give me a very John Green thought
and said well a year from now would have
been better so I'm going to talk about
this in like a weird way now and I don't
want you to think that I'm not
processing this uh in a deeper sort of
more emotional way or with regards to my
personal life it's just that I don't
really want to do that here right now
because it's very heavy
um to talk about the diagnosis
from those perspectives but I do feel
comfortable and ready to talk publicly
about it um in terms of my work whatever
that is which is important you know like
one of the things that I've noticed
about this is that there are
practicalities and this is also true of
like any big unpleasantness in a life
that there's like
Logistics to take care of and so I've
been dealing with a lot of logistics
like who do you tell how do you tell
them what are we going to do about
different things that I'm working on so
I've talked to a few friends who have
been through various different Cancers
and Cancer Treatments and one of the
things that they all said is
this is your job now
do this one day at a time don't have
obligations you can have things that you
can do if you want to that day and it's
good to have those things because
depression and anxiety are a big part of
this and like I'm not a person who has
struggled a lot with that but I have
seen firsthand now how intricately
linked those things can be and the call
of just lay in bed and feel bad is very
strong and even though I don't feel bad
at all right now except for like some
soreness because of the biopsy and and
maybe because my lymph nodes are big I
don't feel any symptoms of this I feel
fine I don't even really feel fatigued
it's hard to tell I feel stressed by a
bad symptom but the moment I start chemo
I'm going to feel a lot of symptoms from
that and uh and they're like that's
gonna be like just dealing with
that is going to be a lot and you're not
going to be good at stuff you're not
going to be good at stuff like don't
expect to be able to do your life so
basically what that means is like what
am I gonna make I don't know am I gonna
make vlogbrothers videos am I gonna make
dear Hank and John am I gonna make
Sideshow and I'm gonna make tangents I
don't know I don't know I don't know I
don't know I don't plan it by ear uh I
know that I'm gonna feel like garbage
like it's gonna be really unpleasant
um you know it's chemo is intentionally
poisoning your body so that the super
hungry cells get poisoned more and die
and that's that's how it works and it
works well
um but like you're you've gotta you
gotta put a lot of poisoning oh now one
of the lovely things about
you know my experience of my colleagues
and and this community nobody's going to
expect me to do anything nobody's going
to be expecting things from me now I do
operate off of obligation and so I do
want some reasons to get out of bed and
I'm going to try and set some of those
up for me but I'm much more worried
about me putting too much pressure on me
to do things or worry about things uh
and so that's going to be something that
I have to get better at you can see this
probably more in my actions than my
words but I'm a very driven person and I
take obligations like I hold them very
seriously and they weigh on me a lot and
cause a lot of stress when there's like
space between what I feel I should get
done and what I feel capable of what I'm
at what I am capable of doing and so
that's what I'm a big worries I'm just
saying it out loud for myself mostly but
also to say I hope you are down with me
making stuff when I feel like it because
I love it and like I need to be doing
things when I feel up for it and also I
know that you'll be fine
with me taking breaks and you know I
don't like this could be I have no idea
it's it's on the order it's not going to
be less than four months of chemo
another thing I'm worried about that's
not a big deal and I know it's silly but
I'm wrestling with the reality that this
is now part of
how people are gonna
imagine me
um it's like it's an identity that I'm
having thrust upon me which happens to
people all the time and is totally the
thing that I will get over but I do like
I do just kind of want to say it out
loud that like I want to be like fun
goofy Science Guy
not like struggling with anxiety cancer
guys
and like you know you could be both so I
think I just have to let that go
um because this it's just one more thing
that I'm not in control of right now
which is a lot of things like there are
things that you have absolute control
over very few and then there's like a
spectrum all the way to you have no
control but now there's just this big
set of my life that I have no control
over and
I'm struggling with that
that's hard that's a that's like a kind
of it's like a thing to grieve and my
last lesson since I have you here is
that all of the time I have ever spent
investing in friendships and and even
when they have been hard to try and keep
them strong and even when I've been busy
to try and uh spend time with them has
been joyful
in the moment
and wise in the long term I have been
I've really needed friends in the last
few weeks and I've been very grateful to
have them I felt very lucky to have
great friends and family uh around to
joke with and hang with and support me
uh and give me the Good Vibes you know
and now I have requests if you could
believe it my my requests are one I do
not need health care advice I have been
very well taken care of I know there are
a lot of different ways and a lot of
different things that are very helpful
to a lot of different people I have that
and people suggesting things to me in my
like World of friends and acquaintances
this is too big of a group for that I
think I would be overwhelmed and more
broadly here are uh non-mainstream ways
to deal with with cancer and to to fight
cancer itself I'm not I find that that
to of course be well-meaning but uh
confusing and distracting and uh not for
me second I'm not really a like let's
fight this thing together kind of guy I
think that the the prognosis for illness
is mostly down to good science good
health care good outlook good attitude
and like chance like it's too much of it
much more than we would like to think
comes down to chance and I just feel
very grateful to all the people who have
spent their careers studying disease and
cancer and Lymphoma and Hodgkin's
specifically which
if you can believe this was originally
thought to be a form of tuberculosis
when it was first discovered in the
early 1900s it's not but they thought it
was
so it all comes back everything is
tuberculosis John all this is to say
like I just I don't need there to be
like a big thing about it I just want
um
y'all to know where I'm at and what's
going on now at the same time I do
understand that people are going to want
to do something like uh and I have a I
have requests I do have things that I
would like from you here are here two
things you can do first if you haven't
you can sign up for our newsletter like
I think knowing me I'm going to still
find joy in creating and communicating
with people if I can and the easiest
lowest lift way of doing that is
probably going to be writing something
down and putting it in a newsletter and
so if I still want that
but I'm not feeling up to making videos
and podcasts that would be a nice thing
to be able to have so you can sign up
for that it's the top thing in the
description and I'd appreciate that
second if you could give me ideas for
movies and TV shows and video games that
are not heavy at all like no emotion I
go watch The Dungeons and Dragons movie
because I think that's gonna be a fun
time and not all of the themes were
restful for me I have to say so really
dumb things that will not make you cry
could not make anyone cry because I've
been told that I'm gonna have some time
to consume media and I desperately need
to be distracted as you can tell I'm
fine uh but I'm not fine and
it sucks like I know that this sucks
most for me but I also know that it
sucks for everybody uh in this community
so
I feel like apologizing but that would
be stupid so I'm not going to but I
think you know what I mean uh I just
want to recognize that it sucks so
thanks I hope this isn't my last
vlogbrothers video for four months or
whatever if it is it is I don't want to
put pressure on me
um John will probably take some time off
because it's just probably a little
weird to post just him on the channel
um so but we'll play it by ear we'll
figure it out as we go
uh one day at a time and uh I continue
to be extraordinarily grateful for so
many of the things in my life including
this and John I'll see you on Tuesday